He blocked me.
What a f--king loser.
I was asked my opinion on this account.
I think the content is inappropriate.
One of the biggest issues
that TikTok has faced
is the hypersexualization
of its youngest users.
The platforms need to do something.
The difference with TikTok
is it encourages you to
perform for the camera.
And what that means is
we're seeing young users
do inappropriate things
to try and get a huge following.
My daughter tries to wear a bathing suit
and that's a frickin' problem?
That has resulted in a groundswell
of older creators questioning
the kind of content
that these kids are putting
out there in the world.
She is describing how to
"stretch her cat."
Where are your parents?
Where are your guardians?
Society, this is not okay.
This is f--king nuts.
They are highlighting what they view
as problematic content
and calling not only the
creators out for making it,
but calling TikTok out
for not enforcing its community guidelines
and banning this type of content.
Call me a prude, call me a Karen,
I don't give a sh-t.
It's twisted,
it's sick,
and it's wrong.
But I'm looking for...
Hi!
Hey, Roselie!
How you doing?
I'm doing good, how are you?
I'm good.
Thanks for having us.
Yeah, of course!
Everybody's just in the room right now,
so I hope you don't mind.
Yeah, yeah, no, that's
cool, whatever works.
Jenny Popach is probably one of the most
successful teen creators on TikTok.
Hi, guys, get ready with me for Halloween.
Her real name is Roselie Arritola,
she just turned 16,
and she has almost
seven million followers.
She gained a huge following on Musical.ly
from the age of 10,
carried that following through to TikTok,
and now she had the ability to expand
to an even wider audience.
She's receiving video views from 300,000
to 4.5 million on a daily basis.
Glad you didn't tidy up for us,
this is Roselie in her natural state.
I debated on, really, like, cleaning,
but I was like let's be natural here.
One of the things with
social media, it's like,
you see the number, but if
you were really to, like,
see all these people in front of you,
you'd really, like,
understand how many people,
the amount of people
that are watching you,
it's definitely satisfying to see that
your creation is getting views,
it's getting likes,
it's getting engagement and comments
'cause, you know, it's like
somebody making a movie,
and they put it out and
it gets amazing reviews,
and it's forever an iconic movie.
Same thing with videos and
content creating on TikTok
and all social media platforms,
the likes and the views and all of that
are just the product, like,
you just see the outcome like that.
Presently in The Hype House right now.
The OG Hype House.
Roselie and her mother
really wanted her to become famous,
so they did everything they
could to get her there.
Stay tuned.
It's gonna be amazing,
we're gonna have amazing content.
Even at the age of 13,
they flew out to the original Hype House,
where a bunch of teenage
creators film content
and try and grow their followings.
Our new junior Hype
House is gonna be neat!
They sneaked into the house,
recorded videos, and, of
course, they went viral.
I had a fish here on an automatic feeder
and the fish tank is
now next to the toilet
with no fish in it.
So...
I'm really sorry if I unknowingly, like,
invaded your guys' privacies,
that was never my intention.
She hit over a million followers
amid that controversy
and that taught her something.
It taught her to lean into
that bad girl persona,
to post content that was
gonna be controversial,
and that she'd get
rewarded for that behavior
by TikTok placing her on its For You page
and putting her out there
on this global stage
to a billion users.
So tell me, what has been
your most popular outfit
that you've worn that
people on TikTok have loved?
My Skims, my Skims,
everybody always loves
when I wear the Skims.
I have a Skims onesie.
It was a Christmas onesie
and I got 3.4 million likes in that one.
Wow.
It fits like a glove.
By the age of 15,
Roselie was getting a
number of brand deals.
Back at it with another Empty Soda haul.
With fashion companies like Shein,
Pretty Little Thing,
or Fashion Nova,
they would send her clothes
and they would pay her
to wear those clothes in the posts
to try and get her followers to buy them.
Hi, you guys!
I just got some clothes
from Romwe and I wanna...
She had become a bonafide influencer
and she was leaning into that
influencer marketing world
where you can make quite a lot of money
from brand deals on TikTok.
The content that does the best for me,
I feel like is spontaneous,
those are always great,
or shock value.
Those are very, like, interesting
'cause if you have something
crazy going on in your video,
it's gonna get more
replays, more rewatches,
and that just makes it skyrocket.
Make sure something shocking is happening
that people will just be
like, wait, wait, wait,
let me take a double take,
and wanna put their input and opinion
and wanna send it to their friends
and want everybody else to see it.
One of the great mysteries of TikTok
is how its algorithm works.
How does it decide what content
to promote on the platform?
In a document called "Algo 101",
the company outlines
how its algorithm works.
The equation is the company saying,
the most valuable content to TikTok
is that which is going to
result in audience engagement
and that's the type of content
that Roselie Arritola is making.
She just is a teenage
girl dancing on TikTok.
But when you dive into her account,
it's caused many people to ask
is this what kids should
be doing online now?
It's insanity to me that this is, like,
a normalized thing,
that we're taking 12, 13, 14 year olds,
dressing them into almost nothing,
and making them famous.
Nobody seems to bat a f--king eye.
People just, when they realize my age,
they're, like, in this shock or disbelief
that I'm so young and they're like,
"Why are you posting things like that?
Why are you dancing on TikTok?
Why are you dancing in crop tops?
Why are you doing this,
why are you doing that?
Just why are you doing you at 16?"
And the funny thing is 'cause, like,
you could go to a school, a public school,
and you'd probably find a
million other 16 year olds
just like me that are wearing
the same clothing as me,
that are doing their makeup just like me,
everything just like I am.
I'm doing what every other
16 year old girl is doing,
I'm just being viewed by a lot of people,
and people think that's
dangerous, I guess.
Why should I not be doing something
that is so kid-friendly and so, like,
normal to teenagers
because the weirdo in the corner
is watching me with provocative thoughts?
Why should we leave?
They should be the ones, you know,
filtered out.
Hey, girlies.
So I wanted to give you
guys a followup video
on Jenny Popach.
It's about three months
since I last talked about her
and her original TikTok page
was banned for a second time.
The most severe action that
TikTok can take against a creator
is to deactivate an account.
We've seen Roselie Arritola's
account deactivated twice
and reactivated twice.
This just kind of goes to show
how much of a problem
child she is for TikTok.
When it comes to the issue of
hypersexuality of minors on the app,
TikTok takes the view that it
cannot look at this content
through the prism of
the predatory male gaze.
It wants to see the video
through the perspective
of the creator who made it
and what that means is that TikTok has an
"if in doubt, leave it up" mantra.
This has really helped Roselie Arritola
because it means that content she's made
that some may say is inappropriate,
that's allowed to stay up
because she has so many followers
and she's created such a
name for herself on the app.
So why do you think you were lucky enough
to get your account back?
I mean, I have, like, 6.7 million,
so it's, like, how can you just, like,
deactivate somebody's account like that
that has, like, worked so hard
and dedicated, like, a lot
of their time to your app?
And also I think that since
it happened once before,
they're, like, oh, well,
she's been banned once before,
like, it wasn't a big deal the first time,
this is just, like, a misconception again,
a misunderstanding,
let's restore it again.
I think one of the biggest questions
for people who follow accounts
like the Jenny Popach account
is where are the parents?
Do the parents allow
her to behave this way?
Are they watching what she's posting?
The answer is yes.
Her parents are often seen
in her videos with her
and that has resulted
in even more questions.
Her father, Jorge Arritola,
sometimes appears in her posts.
He can be seen picking her up
and carrying her out of the frame.
Do you find it strange that
seven million people follow Roselie?
Yeah, I do.
To a certain extent, yeah, I do.
I could understand how I could see
a lot of children maybe
her age and even younger
who wanna aspire to do the same things.
It's just a whole new world,
I didn't grow up like that.
For us, social media was lunchtime.
But yeah, you know,
I just gotta take care of my baby girl.
Why do you think she's become
so successful so quickly?
Because she wants it.
Yeah.
She wants it.
You know?
She's been manifesting it.
It was, like, in the stars for
her or something, you know?
I'm literally a normal 15 year old girl
just going through life on
social media, on the internet.
I guess some people
like to speculate things
when your parents are involved.
This must be a ploy to get money,
they must be exploiting you.
When in reality,
I just have two loving and caring parents
who support the career path
I wanna take with my life.
To become an influencer
is one of the most
sought after professions
for kids these days.
They want to reach that
level of fame online.
They see influencers with
millions of followers
and want that lifestyle.
What this has resulted in is "TeenTok"
or teenagers on TikTok
devoting huge amounts of
time to build their following
and make high quality posts
that are gonna hit that For You page
has kind of become an
industry in and of itself.
The global influencer market
was valued at $13.8 billion in 2021.
This is huge money.
Teenage TikTok is big business.
Did you finish "Stranger Things"?
Yeah.
You did, huh?
I made a TikTok about it.
You did?
Mm-hmm.
Like, look.
Who the hell's that,
dressed like that?
That's me!
♪ Make a deal with God ♪
♪ And I'd get him to swap our places ♪
Oh, that's like a remix, huh?
They sped it up.
You're so pretty.
My little superstar.
Since I work so hard for
my money on TikTok...
What do you wanna do with it?
I kind of just wanna save it
and I guess get a cheap car
and maybe do that stock thing because
could I lose money with the stock thing?
I don't see Amazon going
lower than what it is now.
It's just gonna go back up.
Everybody shops on Amazon.
What I'm saying is I don't
think you should be spending,
like, 15, $20,000 on a car.
I wanna go buy a car, baba.
Really, so that what?
It sits in front of the house?
'Cause you don't even
have a driver's license.
Okay, but when I turn 16, like,
I'm, like, "Baba, I'm leaving in the car."
Yeah, you know what I'll say after that?
Shotgun!
"I'm coming with you."
Shotgun.
With the shotgun.
Oh, my gosh, baba.
There are a lot of safety concerns
with having kids, you know,
as young as 10, 11, 12,
13, all the way to 15
having millions of people
following them online.
We've seen cases where
there's actually been
a real physical danger or risk.
Not only does it open them up
to potential stalking issues
or receiving adult X-rated content
from people they don't know,
it also creates a world
where their content
is being viewed as child
sexual abuse material.
It's stressful at times.
Not only do I worry about her
just being my little girl,
now I worry about her being my little girl
who's on a platform where
there's millions of people
who are watching her.
But if what she does can
help her be a better person,
can make her money
that she could put herself through college
or better herself as
an adult in the future,
then I don't see a parent
who wouldn't want that
for their child,
or who wouldn't try to support it
and protect them as much as they could.
At TikTok,
we want to create an environment
where positivity and
creativity can thrive.
The team that has to handle
minor safety issues inside TikTok
is called Trust and Safety.
We use a combination of
innovative technology
and thousands of safety
experts based around the world.
It has about 40,000 human moderators
around the world
that are viewing TikTok content
and deciding on a daily
basis what to take down
and what can stay up.
Now, for a quick tour of our guidelines.
Our commitment to the community
starts with our policies.
What the Trust and Safety team does
is it writes policies
to try and ensure that
danger is reduced on the app
and that the children
who use the app are safe.
We expect everyone to adhere
to this code of conduct.
In the guidelines,
it says that minors cannot
be seen to be undressing,
cannot be seen to be
dancing in a sexualized way,
but a lot of creators feel as though
they see a lot of teenagers
doing exactly that.
For those who don't know,
that's Jenny Popach.
Every single one of her videos
violate TikTok's adult nudity
and sexual activity guidelines.
This is, like, just disgusting.
Children should not be
allowed to do stuff like this
on this platform.
The Jenny Popach account
has caught the eye of a
number of watchdog creators,
or vigilantes who highlight
child exploitation.
If it was my sis when she was 15,
that predator would
have his whole existence
erased off the face of the Earth.
They are using her content
to raise awareness of just how problematic
the influencer world has become.
No kid should be doing the type of stuff
this little one is doing.
That teenagers, parents, and children
are doing things online
that maybe they shouldn't,
or that maybe one day
they'll grow to regret.
When you share your children
on these public platforms,
you are allowing the worst of society
access to your child's image
and video and information
and that's scary.
So safety is a big concern.
But also, the element of privacy.
It is an invasion of children's privacy
to be exposing their daily
life and their daily existence
as content and as entertainment
for strangers on the internet.
Sarah Adams is a stay-at-home mom
based in Vancouver.
She runs a TikTok account
called "Mom Uncharted"
and she regularly highlights content
that she describes as child exploitation.
Her entire account is
about calling TikTok out
for allowing this kind
of content on the app.
I see grown adult men
commenting and liking the photos
of little girls.
She started looking at Jenny's posts
and I think initially
she just thought that
this was just another teenage girl,
but the more she watched,
she realized this is
actually quite problematic
and there was one post in particular
that she took issue with.
I was reaching out to my community
to ask am I missing something?
Have we skipped forward from 13 to 21?
This feels very new and
uncomfortable for me.
Am I alone in this?
So yesterday I posted a
video from this creator.
And it got this.
I got reported for minor safety.
One thing I don't want is
it ever to be an attack
and I can understand how it is exciting
and validating to receive
all of this attention online,
but just to let them know
that they are so much more
than that sexualized creator
they are on these platforms
and they are more than their body.
We're gonna do the baby's hair.
We haven't done a video
like this in a while, huh?
When Sarah first started using TikTok,
she was really targeting
the mummy-run accounts.
That's accounts where parents are posting
the daily lives of their kids
and Sarah believes that
that is actually akin
to child exploitation.
Little girls make big news
in Long Beach, California.
They're having a beauty parade,
100 of them between the
ages of four and six
competing for the title
of Miss California Junior.
The idea of pageant mums or dance mums
has existed for decades.
We have seen parents push
their kids in these ways
for a really long time.
She's got a lot.
She's tops of all these tiny tots.
The difference with social media
is that it's amplified
the ability to do that.
Now you can do it from the
luxury of your own home,
wherever you're based.
And that allure of fame is
leading a lot of parents
to post content about their kids online
to try and grow these followings.
At no point is it appropriate
to film your 13 year old daughter
in a bathing suit having an
outdoor shower in slow mo
and post it publicly on the internet.
What are these f--king
garbage parents thinking?
I have realized that
there are a lot of parents
who aren't protecting
their own children online.
So if parents aren't going to
protect their own children,
society, individuals like myself,
and creators I work alongside
have to step up and say enough is enough
and hopefully our voices get so loud
that these companies hear us
and the brands who are
supporting this content hear us
and the other adults who
are consuming the content
think long and hard about
what they are consuming
and maybe hit that unfollow button.
Hi, everyone.
This is Steve.
Steve is here to validate my point
that the majority of men
who are in my comments
calling me a Karen and telling
me to mind my own business
because I brought up
minor safety on this app
are indeed the ones
following minors on this app.
They don't want their content to go away.
So thanks for proving my point, Steve.
You are gross.
I honestly don't know how these platforms
are managing on the backend
because if what I am seeing
on my side is worrisome
and that's getting through the cracks,
what isn't making it on there?
That's the one I was telling you about.
It's hard to tell how old she is.
Yeah.
Because they are no
longer 13 to 18 year olds.
Yeah.
They are gone.
All of them look 18 plus.
When talking to Trust and Safety insiders
at TikTok,
content moderation is defined
as an impossible task.
If we just look at the first
three months of this year,
TikTok removed over 100 million videos.
But that's only one percent of the content
that was uploaded in that same period.
10 billion videos were uploaded
in that same three months.
They're continuously struggling with
dialing up content moderation
and dialing it back down.
If they turn it up as high as it can go,
they're accused of over-censoring.
If they dial it all the way back
and allow anything on the app,
they're accused of not
protecting children.
Would you wear this one?
I'll try it on.
And then I wanted you to wear, like,
I have an army dress.
Me?
Yeah.
But I don't know if you wanna...
Is this for your TikTok or mine?
Yours.
Mine?
Yeah, yeah, yes, yes!
Yours.
No.
Please?
Roselie's mum, Maria,
is the true mastermind behind
the Jenny Popach account.
She's encouraged Roselie to
create this online persona.
She encourages her to lean
into shock value content.
And sometimes Maria is
actually in the videos
alongside Jenny,
dancing just as suggestively
as her daughter.
My mom is the girl,
she's my mom, my best friend, my sister,
everything, my partner in this,
and so she basically gives me my ideas,
if I don't have any,
she'll give me a type of video to make.
One, two, ready, go.
Sometimes she even buys my outfits
and she's the one that takes
me to film most of my videos.
Most of my videos that
I've done with my mother
are my most shocking videos.
Three, two, go.
Okay, jump up.
Oh, my gosh.
I always knew that I'd be famous one day.
I didn't know when, but I just knew.
And so, I've aspired to
be that my whole life.
Mommy.
We love the attention.
I've always loved that.
I think I'd take fame over money any day.
Jenny's niche on TikTok would
be basically just dancing
and doing the dancing trends,
but then, like, that gets a
little boring after a while
because nobody wants to
just continuously see this,
we have to switch it up at times,
so we post videos on TikTok
that contain shock value
to attract viewers and
to attract attention.
But as far as being inappropriate,
I mean, there has to be
some sort of shock value
to a video in order for it to
go viral to a certain extent,
so we know what we're doing.
I think people take things the wrong way,
you know what I mean?
But do I think her
videos are inappropriate?
Maybe a couple of them might
have been inappropriate,
but as far as her whole content, no.
Jenny posts a lot of risque content
that would get somebody
my age, 20 years old,
banned from the f--king app.
But no, when kids do it,
when kids do it, it's completely okay.
One of the ways to become
really successful on TikTok
is to post content so controversial
that it's going to result
in people criticizing you,
or attacking you,
or calling out your posts
and that actually ends up boosting them.
This girl is 100% being
exploited by her mom
and it's the most disgusting
thing you've ever seen.
What's so cringy about Jenny Popach?
When other creators
have criticized Roselie
Arritola for her content,
her mother, Maria, is very
defensive of her daughter
and she comes after these creators
to try and shut them down.
I have your address.
I will literally go to your house.
Okay?
You don't think I will?
I will go to your house.
I'm not a troublemaker.
I don't make trouble.
But when you bring it to me,
you know, that's it.
When you talk about my daughter,
yeah, you're talking about me.
Like, whatever you say
about her is affecting me
10 times worse.
And I know people have to create drama
and say things that are not true
in order to get those views.
But come on, at my expense,
at my daughter's expense?
I'm tired of it.
I'm tired of it,
why can't it just be positive?
How many more of these cases will it take
for it to finally come to an end?
The fact that so many
children are being exploited
for fame and money by their own family,
by their own parents?
When is it ever going to end?
I think that she's just
saying what everybody else
sees on social media and, like,
the whole help thing,
I've explained to many people
I was never asking for help.
This is ridiculous.
She only made videos
because she just saw
the other guy's video.
Yeah, everybody's jumping
on the trend to make videos.
So I can get views.
Yeah, to jump on the
trend of making a video
about Jenny Popach
'cause that's what everybody
else is doing right now.
But the exploiting, exploiting?
Here's another one.
And it's all these moms.
I said that about the moms!
The stupid idiot moms.
40, 50 year old mothers, mad.
Mad, why?
Because why?
'Cause their husbands are perverts.
Right?
And probably watching you.
Probably.
It's not our fault.
"What's wrong with this family?"
"What is wrong with this family?
Why are they rich and
poor at the same time?"
"Family getting along
equals everyone confused."
"Something's off."
"You can tell she was forced
to do that last part."
"Are they abusing you?
Are you okay?"
"I feel like it's a
trafficking situation."
A trafficking?
What, I'm literally
standing in the living room
doing a TikTok.
Yeah.
I'll be over this in, like, an hour.
There's been times where
she doesn't wanna do a video
and I'll be like, well,
I have this great idea
and I don't want it to be a waste.
So she'll do the video,
and then of course, since she
didn't wanna do the video,
you could tell in the video
she didn't wanna do it.
So they may take that
one video and be like,
oh, well, her mom made her do that,
and then it's a domino effect.
But it's not an exploitation
and it just kills me inside
to think that people think that of me.
So I'm down the rabbit hole
of these mommy-run accounts again.
We've seen an increasing
number of creators
highlighting the dark side
of influencer culture,
highlighting the problems
of having children online.
But what we don't know
is what the long-term
impacts of that is gonna be
and this is gonna be a problem that TikTok
is going to have to face in coming years.
This issue isn't going to go away.
It's only going to get worse.
And I don't envy TikTok's
Trust and Safety team.
They are stuck in the
middle of this tug of war.
Have you found any particular accounts
that you find really concerning,
that have been shut down?
The ones that have been
shut down always come back.
Always come back.
I haven't seen any
extremely large accounts
be banned and stay banned.
Why do you think that is?
I think accounts of that
magnitude and popularity
make the app money.
It's good for the app.
Shock value,
controversy,
trending topics, you know?
A single account on TikTok
is making national news.
That's good for the platform.
What about for the kids?
It's gonna be tough on the kids.
Yeah.
Girls that are my age,
15, 16, maybe even 14,
I hope that they can
just look at my videos
and feel like they can be like that too
without feeling bad about it
because a lot of people put, you know,
negativity on the way I am.
And I hope that they see me ignoring that
and me still doing me
and ignoring the negativity
and are like, well, if she
doesn't care and if she's okay,
then maybe I can,
and are just influenced
by that, a role model.
Everyone, it's my birthday!